many of you of course want to get that
covid vaccine the rollout has been
anything but smooth
eight news now has learned about another
hurdle now the i-team's vanessa murphy
joining us live from her home studio
with more vanessa
brian first the problem was the state
wasn't getting the vaccine wasn't
getting the doses to nevadans fast
enough
now the state is saying the problem is
there's a vaccine
shortage the state's kovid 19 response
director points to the cashman
center as an example so far it's been a
vaccine site for seniors and priority
groups like first responders but
it's closed today through the weekend
due to a limited supply
state officials say the federal
government has been sending 36 000
doses of the vaccine a week but their
goal would be to get it to
18 000 nevadans a day you can see how
those numbers
just don't add up this is a function of
what we've been talking about for some
time which is
our allocation from the federal
government is not enough
to meet our needs or our capacity at the
state level
covid 19 response director caleb cage
says he's hoping that will change with
the biden administration but
in the meantime while plans may be
underway a note for viewers here if
you're trying to book an appointment
and can't the vaccine shortage state
officials are referring to
may be why and coming up at six
the cdc says nevada is far behind in
getting the doses to nevadans
we're gonna take a closer look at that
reporting live vanessa murphy
eight news now